marvel's second disney plus television
events the falcon and the winter soldier
has finally dropped
continuing the saga of the marvel
cinematic universe's
most patriotic hero captain america as
marvel's third phase came to a close
with the enormous 2019 crossover event
avengers end game the original captain
america steve rogers
retired from his heroic post after
saving the world from thanos
and his infinity stones studded gauntlet
of destruction
after returning the stones to their
correct timelines steve makes the
decision to live out his life with his
long lost love
peggy carter in the past returning to
the present timeline briefly to pass his
shield
onto his good friend sam wilson also
known as the falcon
alongside steve's century-old best
friend bucky barnes sam sets out to
carry on steve's legacy
with a famous shield in his possession
but before he can debut as a new captain
america
the united states government presents
their own option just as a first episode
of falcon and the winter soldier
comes to a close though the new captain
america john walker
is only seen in the hero's distinctive
mask and just for a moment
or two he's played by a pretty famous
face here's why wyatt russell who plays
the new captain america in the falcon
and the winter soldier
looks so familiar the son of superstar
performers goldie horn and kurt russell
and half brother of starlet kate hudson
russell was originally an athlete
playing for multiple amateur and
professional hockey teams
early in his career before quitting
hockey due to multiple injuries perhaps
thanks in part to his family legacy
russell then turned to acting appearing
in small roles in movies like 2011's
cowboys and aliens
and 2012s this is 40. he finally scored
his breakout role in 2014
in the comedy sequel 22 jump street in
the sequel to the 1980s reboot 21 jump
street which was released in 2012
two bumbling cops schmidt and jenko
returned to their undercover beat
heading to college to figure out who's
distributing dangerous street drugs
throughout campus
russell plays zuke a football star who
forms an immediate bond with jenko
much to smith's dismay and is a main
suspect for the pair
ultimately it turns out that zuk's not
actually behind the drug distribution
but just a customer russell isn't the
star of the film but he makes a huge
impact as jenko's new best friend
and it set him up for some huge
appearances going forward
besides blockbusters like 22 jump street
russell's film career has mostly relied
on acclaimed indie movies but he's
certainly become a recognizable movie
star
thanks to these opportunities after his
success in 22 jump street russell joined
the cast of richard linklater's breezy
sports comedy
everybody wants some in 2016 alongside
stars like zoe deutsch
blake jenner and glenn powell and
overall
the film earned positive reviews in 2017
russell played a vital supporting role
in the dark satire ingrid goes west
alongside his future mcu co-star
elizabeth olsen
whose character wanda maximov kicked off
the mcu's television projects with
2021's one division
playing ezra the husband of olsen's
influencer taylor sloan eventually ezra
and taylor are entranced by ingrid
a mysterious new stranger desperate to
invade their lives
russell then went on to appear in the
crime thriller shimmer lake
and the romantic comedy table 19 that
same year
soon he's set to appear in the buzzy new
literary adaptation
the woman in the window joining a cast
that includes huge names like amy adams
and gary oldman as well as his falcon
and the winter soldier co-star anthony
mackie
which premieres on netflix on may 14
2021.
russell has built up a solid film career
but beyond the falcon and the winter
soldier
he's shown brightly on the small screen
after appearances in the 2013 walking
dead web series the oath and the 2013
arrested development reboot
russell took center stage in a popular
2016 black mirror episode
playtest where russell's cooper agrees
to test a new implant that allows for
gamers to place themselves within video
games
two years later russell won over
audiences and critics for the leading
role in amc's sadly short-lived series
lodge 49 as former surfer sean dud
dudley
who stumbles across the mysterious lodge
49 and finds himself sucked into the
cultish lifestyle
most recently russell appeared in the
mini-series the good lord bird
which stars ethan hawk in a recurring
role as confederate army lieutenant jeb
stewart
you can see russell going forward in the
falcon and the winter soldier
which airs new episodes every friday
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu tv shows and movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you